Archer fish are the snipers of the
animal world they use their mouth to
make water pistols that can hit insects
meters away to fire the fish compressed
their gills forcing water through a
barrel made by their tongue in the roof
of their mouth but how do archer fish
accomplish such outstanding marksmanship
to find out scientists at the University
of by droit in Germany trained
archerfish to shoot targets of different
heights then they filmed them with a
high-speed camera the team found the
fish could adjust the speed of the Jets
with pinpoint accuracy so they were most
focused and forceful just before
reaching a target Archer fish controlled
their water jets by skillfully opening
and shutting their mouths when they need
to hit a faraway target the fish spray
water for a longer period of time
opening their mouth gradually sort of
like wah with a nearby target Archer
fish form their Jets a couple
milliseconds more quickly more like wah
but the result is the same pow a hit and
a delicious meal the researchers see
parallels between the fish's water
pistol and our own ability to throw
throwing might have spurred our
ancestors to develop bigger brains and
could have led to our superior intellect
so who knows what Archer fish made you
next after all
they can already shoot like James Bond
you